I'm gonna freak out a little bit this is
a moment a Parent Trap reunion at the
SAG Awards do we have you to think for
this well I invited my date but then my
date flew and it took her 19 hours to
get here because of the weather and a
little diversion to Vegas uh three other
planes that were made late and she got
here and I got here and I was determined
she asked me to be her date I showed up
as her date she just showed up look at
her I know look at you the best looking
Daytona tux I think I've ever had
mean this is gonna be a fun night huh oh
yeah did you guys get to get together
well Elaine's in Atlanta now so not as
often as we used to when we lived in the
same city we were together every week
yeah every other night so was it worth
it getting to La by Planes Trains and
Automobiles I will do anything for this
lady so absolutely
so wild too is recently Quinta sat next
to Lindsay Lohan at Paris fashion week
right New York Fashion New York Fashion
Week I mean were you freaking out when
you saw that photo a little bit it was a
little world's colliding but I loved it
and they got along so well and they're
the same age I can't believe it that's
mind-blowing
that is wild to me I just love that the
internet was like you know these two are
just gushing about Lisa and Walter right
now right they both texted me afterwards
and said that that that's what was
happening so I was just like I mean I
love them both so much I love you both
so much I want to talk about fashion
real quick you guys tell me a secret
about each look I'll start with you oh
my gosh well I mean the secret about the
secret about my look is no secret at all
I showed up to be Lee Sam Walter's date
and when she asked me I was like oh I
knew exactly what I needed to wear so I
got a ladies tuxedo it's my first one
ever and I'm madly in love with it it's
giving Marlena Dietrich this is not
exactly what I said that's exactly what
I said I said listen if you're doing
this you're going full Marlena you're
going smokey eye hair in a bob little
hair except we have sort of matching
hair accessories yes I love it so yeah
you better Vogue I love it I love it 100
okay now you have a secret are you
wearing the dress you told us you're
gonna wear which you've had for six
years yes I had it I I got it it was
almost six it was about five years and
four months ago I was at a store
downtown and I said I'm gonna wear this
to the SAG Awards now mind you I was
entirely unemployed
so everyone's like gagging because
they're like you manifested this and I
showed it to my mom who is has passed
and I'm I'm sort of carrying her with me
I've got my Nana's shoe clips on the
front of my shoes and so I've got my
mom's lucite clutch from the 50s so it's
a little bit of an homage